you have a one-man show the new york
story and
yes one of your points is you feel new
york has changed how has new york
changed colin new york and la have both
changed and new york has changed because
there's no characters because people are
afraid
to say anything you know obviously in
the climate we live in in the country
so the new york a construction worker
sees a girl walking by now he's like hey
look at that strong independent woman
you know
and uh yeah hey
ump you're crazy no offense to anyone
with mental illness in their family
i know but la so new york has lost
the whole point of new york was the
whole world wants to be tolerant and
positive and non-judgmental yeah that's
good not new york and of course
boston is the other uh i'll talk about
la in one second let me just side
back to boston because i was in boston i
realized it's the only place
everywhere else like oh you know that
you know from here
this person from mad men all the
celebrities boston you're like hey
ma ben affleck's from here
my friend knocked over his coffee he
didn't do anything
you know marky mark my cousin beat the
piss at him in the foxborough mall
yeah no i'm from what's an autograph i'm
from boston and that is exactly how they
are
and that's i went to the i showed i've
told this story before but i showed up
at logan airport and i'm walking there's
a long line
for to get in the taxi cab and i'm
walking towards the back of the line
like i got my suitcase and i'm going to
go like this
yeah and i'm walking with my suitcase
towards the back of the line and before
i can even get to the back of the line
the guy running the line goes like
hey back of the line movie star
i'm like i'm not in the i'm not in the
movies and i was headed to the and the
whole line looks at him like what is
that [ __ ] doing
that that's that's a very irish attitude
like don't think you're getting too big
but the thing about l.a la when i was
first here in the 80s
back in the 80s and um it was a it had
its mojo
somewhere in the because of technology
you let those nerds in northern
california
start to shame you where you guys feel
instead of being the hedonist that you
are you start going we have to be smart
too and suddenly
they're trying to be intellectuals they
you know la's get like this whole
activism awareness you guys are
beautiful just sit by the pool in the
lounge chair that's your job
look pretty okay look pretty yeah and
now look the water the drink you think
they're gonna
send the water back down when you guys
are just starving to death spitting on
your lawn
no that place was supposed to be your
your mini bar you went up there
north napa valley then you come back
down the same night and now they you
know
you gotta go up there and beg some 25
year old nerd for
10 million dollars you know invent an
app where you can have sex and find the
best
froyo place in
[Applause]
there's no app where you get sex in the
best froyo place
all proved oh yeah
nothing isn't even real
i have a phone